so I'm getting three blocks which is a
little bit annoying
[Music]
Hey
my 96
[Music]
ladies night pd-2 which before 2285 prep
combined multi-level
[Music]
concentrate 100% do not mind us please
d3 okay I don't put some supports move I
think eh five is completely fine to
exclusion b2
please night of three I can take on c4
with h2 three is correct
Oh 25 I knows and moved here I was
actually the best move
yeah this is maybe a pretty part
this night eh Fornaio g5 is also moved
here
as its Queen d1 and Bishop e7 I think
chief thought
you know I know night h2 is a move here
am I missing
mrs. queenie for 24 Queenie's
I'm threatening this tree tonight eh -
my latest is just waiting threatens mean
retinas
I guess she's just meaning for you
Iranian mosquito yes indeed now I can
play queen d1 here a night if one looks
fine
let's do though if I take
take that's no good I guess I just
I can also play chief or here as well
I'm gonna play chief or maybe
maybe it's got ok takes
I can take but I think I should just
take the rook here so he takes this is
really really bad for why like
okay let's see I can play with d8 I also
just take the pawn so many options here
it's hard to figure out what's best but
I'm go play rook da because it looks
logical to take the D file
yeah he's 54 I think I still see five
days Rick see one
I think we need four
I gave him cleanup for
careless bill 23 looks good
Thank You belzebub for the tier 2 get to
sub
what's this what oh it's not see me
shoot
completely missed me before I guess we
need to to hit the bishop bishop d5 is
coming they should still be winning
though
23:55 really hard to see why it's
surviving this
you
I think this is just winning
then we should be five the threat
yeah I think was just winning you guys
so it looks like I should be up 1-0
it's the game thought over okay he does
resign okay
[Music]